Build It.
Draw It.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it
The wind portal is a 26 foot high gate composed
of thousands of paper wind mills.
Commissioned by the V&A Museum it's on display
in London.
The wind portal signifies the change of walking
from one space into another and it gives the
viewer a trompe oeil effect as they approach
because it looks closed from a certain angle
but as you approach it appears to open up.
KYL21 are geometric popsicles invented by
David Marx, the founder of Kitchen Science
Berlin.
The mathematical pops are free of additives,
organic, and even come vegan and lactose free.
They're only available at certain events
at the moment and their motto is Healthy Ice
Cream and Exact shapes.
Otto Diefenbach creates RC flying sculptures
for fun and for promotional advertising.
You may have already seen this recent build
of his broom-flying wizard but also check
out this broom-flying witch that he made just
in time for Halloween.
And his website includes other creations like
Superman, Mrs. Emerson, and Iron Man.
Draw it
Kenji Alucky of Black Ink Power does intricate
stipple tattoos with geometric designs.
They're so well done and detailed that they
plays tricks on your eyes when you look at
them.
He's from Japan, but tours regularly visiting
popular tattoo shops.
Check out his website for more.
Zestydoesthings has a series of psychological
disorders as real monsters.
Each one has a specific monster character
and a story to go with it such as anxiety,
depression, schizophrenia, paranoia, and dissociative
identity disorder.
And now for Check Please! a collection of
art left on guest checks...
Vsauce2 fan Ana Siqueria makes amazing body
paint art based off of the tile work of Athos
Bulcão.
The ongoing series is called Habitathos and
is living art painted on people in front of
the famous tile work found in Brazil.
It takes her up to 8 hours to do the body
painting with the scene captured by photographer
Celso Junior.
Rob Prideaux is a still life and product photographer
based in San Francisco that did an amazing
series of photos called Smoke and Fire.
He has a great quote on his website that sums
up his body of work that says "Making good
ideas beautiful and bad ideas interesting."
Play it
Living piano is a project by TFO canada where
singers create a live "piano"
Check out these two University of Washington
students drumming with pens.
Lucas Miller, the Singing Zoologist has a
parody of Katy Perry's Firework called "Baby,
You're An Arthropod"
Finally here's the beautifully animated new
video from Kvelertak for their song Evig Vandrar.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio - music created and submitted
by you guys.
Also check out YOUR BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to just your creations.
And as always - thanks for watching.